problems getting out because as I was
trying to get out there were things and
debris and bits coming off the building
flying down there was some security
barriers in by the bottom of the stairs
where we got stuck we couldn't get out
of the building because we you know you
need a Keith up and luckily we had a fob
there was no alarm there was no bail
there was no sense of an and urgency the
fire was all-consuming devastatingly
quick and it was the worst fear of
residents who had raised general
concerns about fire safety in the past
why were they ignored the investigation
will likely focus on the cladding which
experts believe accelerated the blaze
rain screen cladding curtain wall
facades and replacement windows were all
fitted to improve the thermal insulation
and modernized the look of the building
what you have with the gap between the
insulation and the extreme external
cladding is in effect a chimney the fire
gets out of the flat it sets fire to the
insulation the flames start rising they
rise through the gap between the
cladding and the insulation because it
can touch the whole of the surface
according to a planning document it was
only added to improve the view of the
building for the surrounding area which
includes luxury flats and conservation
sites that we've discussed with the de
Pompadour government local authorities
and the fire service or process whereby
we seek to identify towers that might be
in a similar process of refurbishment
run a system of checks especially so
that we as quickly as possible give
reassurance to people the tower had
stood for decades but was refurbished
only last year a typical floor is said
to have four to bed apartments and two
one-bedroom apartments with one central
staircase and two lifts a new smoke
ventilation system was installed in the
lobby with a detector and a signal on
each floor connected to a central system
this smoke ventilation system was
designed to protect the stairwell from
smoke if there were a fire within a flat
the main fire escape on the ground floor
was from the box
in club lobby the contractor responsible
for the nine point seven million pound
refurbishment was ridin their
headquarters are in Kent we spoke on the
phone and worked
shall we just be with the director make
someone know that we're not available
for entities at the moment we have a
press statement the statement said
Royden completed a refurbishment of the
building in the summer of 2016 for the
Kensington and Chelsea tenant management
organization on behalf of the council
which met all required Building Control
fire regulation and health and safety
standards this tower just by the
Grenfell tower was built at the same
time to the same standard fire expert
explained how its safety features are
designed there's one for escape that's
enough yeah because one of limited is a
travel distance from the potential fire
sort and to stare dial stared corner
protected zone
there's no combustibles in here our very
very minimal therefore the snow far
source and should be in fast great
potential therefore people can move from
the flood through the app door through
the first lobby doors with the shaking
lobby doors the middle thumb lobby door
and enter via court then moving through
increasing levels of safety the
Kensington and Chelsea tenant management
organization acknowledged that issues
had been raised by residents and said
they would form part of the forthcoming
investigations we do look listen to
residents I've got eight residents on my
board who are very concerned about these
things and we address them in and get to
the bottom of it I can't really comment
what other climbers are saying at the
moment I've listened to kinds of Padgett
Brown the leader of the council I think
along with the police in the fire
brigade we're just trying to work out
resolve where we are at the moment and
then we'll all contribute to the
investigation to find out the causes
rather than responsive what people say
those investigations will take time
right now there are many questions but
very few people willing to give answers
Tom Cheshire Sky News